with this and everything around this
movie it's it's an untouchable character
with old-school fans why would anyone
want to put themselves you have to be
crazy you know I think that one of the
fun things about all that is taking that
challenge yeah it's in a way you're
doing that is part of what you're doing
is taking on this responsibility and the
challenge of that and navigating all
that is is kind of a great it's very
exciting yeah but the the period of time
of where you can't say anything yes
is that maddening yes it's crazy because
you have the role and you can't tell
your friends you have the role right
it's wild and then from shooting it even
until now yeah I mean you spoil the
movie you lose a job right absolutely
yeah that's your constant it's like
being in the CIA right constantly in
fear of whatever I had the role and who
and it was released that I that I had it
in the press so people are coming up to
me and saying congratulations and I'm
like afraid to say thanks I'm like okay
okay yes for for being at this
restaurant yes you see what happens to
people in star wars star wars has a
thing of where once you're in it you're
in it for life it's a lifelong
commitment that you've learned this
isn't one movie this is now your life
moving forward forever are you cool with
that sure yeah you take on I think when
you say yes to one of these things which
is something they were more for one yeah
exactly you you sit and you really think
about all of it you know for at least I
did I really it was because it's fun is
and as great as I knew the movie was
gonna be I also you know you have to
kind of make peace with that with
yourself of all the things and kind of
throw yourself into whatever happened
yeah could you give up a lot you'll gain
a lot but then alive and you have this
kind of adventure you spend you know I
spent like two years in England yeah
basically working on yeah did you I mean
as a kid we all tried to learn a little
Wookiee have you done that before the
movie no we've never done
I but I had to learn from my audition
you did yeah what did you do
I watched there's like YouTube videos
really you have like fans and stuff that
teach you how to date oh yeah there's
there's probably tons of yeah I watched
one and and sort of work done it a
little bit now is that's one of the
skills is an actor that you need to
maintain that you need to make sure that
you start plan on doing that in all my
work for happen I'm gonna just bring
that up just a little bit I'll just be
in the scene I know I can't believe
she's dead and before I let you go at
what point did it hit you I am in a
freaking Star Wars movie I think when I
did my screen test on the Millennium
Falcon I wasn't in it yet but I knew I
was it was real Star Wars when I saw the
Karelian blood stripe I remember
thinking wow this is Star Wars yeah
amazing have you seen your action figure
yet because I have yeah are you cool
with it I'm pretty cool with it yeah I
found myself playing with it a lot yeah
I was in the car and I was kind of
playing with it
and I was like oh this is pretty cool
Emma Knight sort of just I spent so many
hours as a kid doing that and it's her
now they make them you know like the
wrists move and the ankles there's so
much the design is a whole other thing
Donald and I were talking about that
right amazing thank you so much thank
you David right on